how does they fit and have you are
working in a full-time job
this is a question that so many of us
are asking ourselves and I know from my
time working it becames see how
difficult it can be to manage the high
pace job the whole workload with staying
healthy with keeping to your daily
health routines today I have something
very special for you because I have a
guest here with me I have Maria with me
who is a true expert on living the
healthy life I know you would love her
you would take so much value out of all
the tips that she will give you but to
start properly welcome to my channel for
learning my name is Jaime and this is
the right place for all the tips tricks
and strategies to be successful in the
first years of your career it's always
if you're taking any value out of this
video at all and I know that you were at
this time please hit the like button for
the YouTube algorithm
you know subscribe to my channel for
even more content for me I have a
release at least one video every
Saturday and if you want to see even
more content for me also follow me on
Instagram my hand and is firm learning
them using new content pretty much every
single day for you and on my Instagram
channel I made a little survey I asked
you guys whether you struggle s-wave
with keeping a balance between working
at a full-time job and also staying fit
exercising and doing all these things
that we all know are so important and I
must say the reside surprised me a
little bit because over 80% of you said
that yes I do struggle with this this
way so this gives me some hope because
apparently I'm not the only one who
struggles with these things and this
tells me that probably this video was
even more necessary than I thought so
I'm very excited for what is about to
come for this great interview looking
forward to that thanks for watching as
well and let's get right into it so here
I am back and I'm having buried with me
buried thank you for being here this is
so amazing to have you today
celery maybe just want to briefly
introduce yourself who are you what
qualifies you to speak about these
topics
thanks for having me hi rich hi everyone
I'm Murray and I used to work
in a law firm and worked 80 hours a week
and I know the struggles of having and
establishing a very healthy lifestyle
especially for those who don't want to
be very stressed or depressed and
struggle on how to establish a very
healthy lifestyle it's amazing but
there's more than that why I think it
was some Road book or something that oh
yeah I did write a book or two books one
book on establishing a healthy lifestyle
including a lot of recipes for you and
then also time management book but
that's not the topic of today's video
that's amazing and I'm sure that in the
end maybe we also have some opportunity
to maybe even also shorter book and
maybe you can say a few words on that
but I'd say before that let's directly
jump into the topic right so here on my
channel we talk all about how to be
successful in the first years of your
career and of course for all of us for
all these viewers out there it's just so
important also to get these two things
under one head on the one hand side of
course the high paced job but then also
the health life one of the dimensions
one of the things you are thinking about
when getting your life what do you
believe other Wedeman fix it so I would
say there are four topics the four
topics start with a morning routine
which I will describe later on then
obviously working out and then food so
food is a very very important part of a
very healthy lifestyle
and the last one is sleep I know you do
get too little sleep but yeah if you
maybe cut some one or two things maybe
you do have some more sleep and I'd say
oh that's a perfect swatch almost as if
you are a consultant it's amazing but
then it start with a morning routine
actually so and frankly I tried that a
couple of times to do some you know yoga
and meditation in the morning and so on
but I miserably failed with all these
things most of the time so worried what
are the components that you would
recommend for a morning
Tina give some tips on how to make these
things actually stick to your life I
mean those are two different topics so
what I do suggest is that you start with
baby steps every routine starts with
establishing maybe one step and then you
get couldn't go from one step to the
second step so my first step would
always include drinking a warm glass of
water with some lemon juice and I know a
lot of you guys you stay in four and
five star hotels every hotel has some
lemon juice and if they don't have some
fresh lemon juice they do have those
sachets with some lemon juice and you
can just pour it in a warm glass of
water or if you don't have a water
bottle on your hotel room you can just
take a glass of sink water tap water
lemon water is important for you because
it boosts your metabolism and starts
your metabolism so it's really important
to start your your day not by drinking
something cold because it actually
shocks your stomach but drinking
something warm too like welcome the day
so I do know that interesting okay so
warming us with lemon juice is there
something more to it no actually that's
it and then obviously the morning
routine would include a small workout
but then we're already at the workout
set section you do not always have to
include your workout in the morning but
I would suggest you to include in the
morning because in the evening I mean
that's that's my impression then you're
too tired and you're too stressed and
probably your partner or project leader
demands a lot of time of you so do it in
the morning and you I promise you will
be much better and refreshed interesting
person you have to say for me it always
been so much more difficult to work out
in the morning than in the evening but I
guess that's maybe also the question of
personal type and and preference but
okay I understood your accommodations to
do it in the morning any any other
things what other elements are core to a
good morning routine from your
perspective I mean obviously it does
include getting up a bit earlier then
you tend to get up so probably the most
of you have a lifestyle where they try
to sleep
the much they can so their timer maybe
gets up at 7 or 8 and then you just have
a short shower and then you rush down to
the buffet and you just stuff into the
food and then you head to the client now
that was me for years
um so what I recommend just maybe start
by getting up a half an hour or earlier
then drink your warm glass of water and
then maybe just do 20 minutes and I
promise you once you establish that
routine you will you will feel the
differences I understand I mean there's
also all the soil element of mindfulness
right just in the morning not starting
the day off completely you rushed and
stressed already because you're really
late and you're time I just went on a
couple of minutes later than you hoped
for and just you know is this a thing
mindfulness what can you do without a
big time invest in the morning to start
off the day in a mindful way I do always
include a very short meditation I know
it's a lot to ask of you to start like
to include a workout and also that were
massive water so I walked out of water
that's quick right ok ok so then maybe
start with five minutes of meditation
and my tip for a good meditation is try
to find a very quiet seat and then close
your eyes and do a body scan if you are
interested in that body scan I can link
you some interesting videos on that
nothing else is gonna do for sure so
we're gonna then link to a few key
resources that Murray recommends below
about interesting concept okay good so
that's the morning routine anything else
you'd like to add to that I think that's
it for now let me summarise that it's
the
one glass of water with the lemon juice
is some basic exercise but you're going
to talk about more in a minute about and
that it's also some more vegetation five
minutes or so for some basic mindfulness
exercise I think doesn't matter how late
the last night was doesn't matter how
busy we are we can always find the time
for drinking a certain glass of warm
water and also five minutes meditation
but now of course the next thing is
exercise and now you also said that you
would like to recommend that to do that
in the morning I mean when I exercise
that can easily take 30 minutes 60
minutes that is quite a big time invest
in the morning right that's that's
totally true you don't have to invest 30
to 60 minutes there are a lot of
disbeliefs that you need a lot of time
for working out and to have good work
out you have to work out long that's
that's wrong already like if you do
bodyweight exercises it doesn't have to
be a run or it can just be maybe some
some exercises on a youtube channel you
like where you use some bodyweight a
very good exercise I would always
suggest is planking because it's
stabilizes your back muscles and
obviously it's good for you sitting very
very long hours on a project or maybe
some push-ups which are really
beneficial as well or sit-ups so how
much time do you need to invest from
your recommendation in the morning and
so what is the time budget that you
should take you I would recommend start
with 15 to 20 minutes every day I mean
obviously if you don't do it every day
in the beginning it's not that bad but
just like starting routine is really
beneficial for you yeah I need to
something out that will be known 15-20
minutes of exercise than 5 minutes of
meditation than drinking a glass of
water so probably that would mean an
investment of about half an hour which I
know it can be sometimes quite tough if
you really work super late an evening
but then probably have an hour to just
start your day in the right mood just to
make sure that you're set up right
probably in the long term that
really be worth your time right exactly
I mean there are a lot of people that
after a long work day they check their
social media and if I can make one
suggestion cut the social media usage I
know it's very addictive and obviously
makes fun to check your Instagram
stories or any Facebook posts I know
that but out of your five-day week or
maybe a four-day week at the client just
cut the four days and you still have
three days where you can like binge on
Instagram though of course there's one
exception and this is watching videos on
my channel that of course you should
always be but yes I completely recut oh
yes that's a good point
I mean how I always thought about that
when I were at McLean's in the exercises
that I always try to get three units of
like longer exercise sessions and now I
actually hopefully read that actually no
recommended doing a little session every
single morning right probably more
tamiya to get you started to get a man's
not then we have to do some serious
training but then I always hope to do
with three sessions on top of that and
what I always did was Fridays on Friday
evening I was able to get off the office
a bit earlier so then that for sure was
our session and then also either
Saturday or Sunday I would go for a
second session and then there was only
one session that I needed to somehow fit
within the work week of let's say Monday
to Thursday and my my perception was
that somehow if I really wanted to then
was always possible right so doesn't
matter how tough the project was or
difficult it was there was always some
time for me it wasn't evening because
that was just my personal preference to
get a maybe a one hour run in don't you
stay on Wednesday also I would almost
always able to then discussed and also
some sausage with my project lead with
my team need just to get that time in
and then maybe that booked me that maybe
I already had a very quick - no no - no
- or maybe then afterwards I went back
to my desk and then continued working
but getting the little exercise unit in
that was always possible for my
experience yeah definitely so so that's
a good routine that
establish like always having three
workouts a week I mean if you have one
day in a week in your four days of
Project Work and everybody knows
especially your boss knows then that's
reason that the boss will leave you
alone at that time so if that the boss
knows okay hi nurse goes running at 7
p.m. and he always goes running at 7
p.m. on a Monday he knows that's your
holy time and everyone also your
colleagues will be doing thank you and I
think a complete degree Murray in there
oh I always did it especially when I was
an associate any one side and what's the
project lead of course you maybe I apply
a bit more flexibility you're organized
a day but in the beginning of the
project I always made sure to have such
a conversation with my project in with
my teammate they had kind of a two-sided
conversation what was really important
to me in terms of the way of working and
handing all these things and what was
important for the project lead and then
he said McKinsey there's a bit of a
culture true just in a standardized way
having these conversations right so this
was quite typical but then I always made
it clear that it was just very important
for me to get a proper unit of freedom
or exercise and once every week from
Monday to Thursday and I always try to
also pick one day to make that stick and
to make everybody know and then from my
experience even though of course the
characters of projects and so on can be
quite different right but for my
experience there was always the
possibility to kind of discuss this and
agree with the project lead of that and
they're just Frank's this is important
just to be explicit just make it pretty
clear that this is your expectations and
associate could be able to do that and
usually we will find that people will
agree right and there should be an
opportunity once a week to have an hour
of sports out of your evening all of
your morning right so people will agree
in this will be possible but it's also
matter of you demanding that of you
making it clear that this is really
important to you just my two cents on it
yeah no good so that's I think that's
exercise so let's not jump to the third
topic and this is food and I know this
is a topic you're especially passionate
about exactly so in my book I promote
vegan gluten-free and no sugar lifestyle
I know this sounds very strange for
maybe a lot of you guys and I don't
recommend everyone of you to cut
everything from one day to the other I
know how you love your steak and you
love your meat but what I would
recommend for everyone who can who has
some time I mean don't don't really need
a lot of time to eat healthy is maybe
start with cutting the sugar I know
especially on a very long workday those
chocolate bars are very tempting yeah
and obviously the longer you work the
better they taste so let's talk about a
typical day of somebody working in a law
firm or a consulting firm on a busy
corporate job what would you recommend
to eat at the different times of the day
so I would have three big meals I would
start with breakfast which is oatmeal
and keeps you full for a couple of hours
then I would eat a light lunch maybe
some salad with some proteins and maybe
something warm in the evening if you do
have the time to eat something warm and
as a snack I would include two snacks I
would include some nuts and some dried
fruit why not they're especially good
for your brain health so I would
recommend eating walnuts if you're not
allergic to them obviously they're very
very good for your brain health I mean
and just through to 2nd ed right so also
especially these these necks in the team
room I mean this is such a trap right
and there are so many experiences that I
had in the team room retinas people
started to buy chocolate just leave it
there for everybody just to eat and this
is just so difficult than to resist the
temptation and for my experience in the
end what it always came down to if you
want to change that it was always up to
one person in the team then just to
stand up and say hey guys let's not have
these chocolates mixed all the time but
let's get some other snacks there's
somebody taking the initiative and then
organizing some others
from the supermarket Ronix corn or
whatever your opportunities are familiar
places whenever the client was so why is
it should that be you right so just take
the initiative if you believe that your
team is developing really unhealthy
habits because then of course often it's
also to yourself eating unhealthy take
the initiative yourself and just make an
impact say that you want to change that
and then trust me everybody in the team
will be grateful for it yeah exactly so
what I promote in my book is a vegan
gluten free and no added sugar lifestyle
and obviously those chocolate bars do
count to sugar so just maybe stand up
and tell your teammates no chocolate
bars any longer and if it's some bars
then maybe it's the very healthy nut
bars you can buy in a supermarket ism'
this is also one of my experiences I
just remember one tea my head we're just
we develop this habit of pretty much
once a week or so we just bought from
the supermarket you would box of nut
bars and I mean maybe then they also had
a little bit of chocolate on that value
no not like a chocolate bar but probably
this still wasn't the most healthy snake
out there but it was much better than
you know these usual bars of chocolate
or candy that you just unfortunately
have so often in these few rooms but be
careful I know it's a it's a good thing
to start with nut bars there are a lot
of nut bars especially in supermarkets
that include a lot of sugar maybe just
turn the nut bar around and then look
for added sugar that's the thing you
always want to look out added sugar if
it's naturally included it's not that
bad for you yeah we don't want added
sugar
okay that's a thing some some great
insights into the food let's now come to
sleep I mean and again this is just such
a difficult topic you're just
chronically constantly sleeping not
enough and fortunately on so many
products do we have any suggestions what
you can do to maybe just improve the
quality of your sleep or just the summer
what's there then
nevertheless the extent of the sleep
what are your suggestions on that okay
so obviously I cannot change your
working hours
that's something you can change and if
your partner demands that slide to be
finished maybe at 2:00 a.m. in the
morning obviously you cannot say no well
I would not necessarily agree with that
I mean there are some ways you can push
back on us on that but maybe that's a
topic for another video change it okay
so obviously then a lot of you guys take
out their phone when they're already in
bed and then they start checking
messages this is something I would cut
it's proven that if you check your phone
and also check a screen directly before
you start sleeping your sleep is much
worse than if you don't
so if it's possible for you try to half
an hour before you go to sleep not check
any screens any longer a and B try to
meditate for five minutes before you
sleep sit down your hotel room close
your eyes and then do a body scan and
when you sleep what is also really
healthy and what promotes good sleep is
a lavender maybe 11 your oil you can rub
on your your temples and lavender is
proven to promote good sleep okay I've
never tried that but maybe you could try
that out in the future
good and just two things also was
heading from from my experiences working
in consulting with what iff was really
helpful to tenure tip so first in the in
the early years of working consulting I
just drank so much coffee all day even
until late in the evening and I just was
convinced that it didn't really affect
me in the sense that I was still able to
sleep even though I just drank several
cups of coffee anything that and what I
then realized over time is that while it
was true while it was correct that I was
still able to sleep
somehow I realized that the quality of
my sleep left a bit right and then I did
a bit of research and I found out that
the half period time of coffee can take
up to four to five hours and I found it
Pilon saying let's this
the view if you have a cup of coffee at
6:00 p.m. in the evening that means that
then around midnight you still have half
of the coffee coffee in your body and I
mean that really make me thinking and
that made me realize that probably I
shouldn't drink coffee or take another
source of coffee you know in the
afternoon so I usually try after 3 p.m.
4 p.m. not drink any coffee anymore and
be subjectively afraid that my sleep
improved and the second tip that I
develop over time - over time that for
me it really had to put the smart phone
on airplane mode while I sleep and not
sure why exactly I'm sure this is
because all the frequencies that maybe
don't happen anymore mean I'm not sure
there's any scientific rationale for
that or maybe just you know knowing that
the foam will not disturb you that
nobody will call you not anything that
but just having the phone on airplane
mode that is for me you really improved
my sleep quality than all the time great
idea
quit so yeah anything you'd like to add
on that no I think that's one section
obviously as well try to reduce your
coffee intake rather drink some green
tea instead of the caffeine but I think
everyone can handle that the way they
like no perfect so I think that's not
has been invited comprehensive
discussion so we talked about morning
routines we talked about exercising
about food about sleep so thank you very
much Marie but not most I like to give
you the opportunity just throw introduce
your new book and it what is it Thanks
so this is my new book you can buy it on
Amazon as a print on demand or an e-book
so if you're on your job then you can
maybe download it on your Kindle or
maybe your iPhone and yeah it does
conclude a lot of recipes that are very
very healthy such as some oatmeal some
maybe some almond mousse or some some
porridge and then maybe how to start
your day here you see the lemon water as
I already discussed and obviously book
two is already in the making so I hope
you will buy my book and I hope you like
it I can completely second that and it's
a great book I read it myself and of
course we leave a link to the book below
in the video description so check it out
and think of a read that's it I really
appreciated here this interview with
viewer thing there are some really great
intangible tips that we all can profit
from so again if you took any value out
of the video at all please hit the like
button for the YouTube algorithm to have
this video be found by many more people
as well and please also subscribe to my
channel for even more content on how to
be successful in the first years of your
career so thank you again Marie thank
you all of you watching out there I
really appreciate your time this is
Jaime from learning and see you next
Saturday